them and that's where we're going to
begin with the news that you probably
were talking about a lot this weekend
because there are a lot of unanswered
questions surrounding president trump
this morning
as he continues his treatment for the
coronavirus so he went for a brief ride
in his motorcade outside walter reed
medical
walter reed military medical center
rather yesterday
just so he could wave to supporters now
some health experts say
this outing put other people the secret
service agents
in the suv at severe risk it is a sealed
vehicle
briefings led by the president's doctor
sean connelly provided little clarity
the medical team said mr
trump could be discharged today even as
they describe
treatment that is more typical for a
severely affected
patient ben tracy is at the white house
for us ben good morning to you so simple
question do we have an accurate picture
of how the president is doing the answer
is no and that's because the president's
doctors and white house officials have
been giving conflicting and confusing
information about the president's
condition all weekend long
we do know the president is awake this
morning he's been tweeting about
everything from the stock market to
democrats
apparently trying to show people he's
just fine
i learned a lot about kovid i learned it
by really going to school in a new video
from his hospital suite last night
president trump says he finally
understands coronavirus
seven months into the crisis that has
killed nearly 210
000 americans this is the real school
this isn't the let's read the book
school
and i get it and i understand it
the president then got in his suv and
went out to wave to supporters gathered
outside
he was wearing a mask and the white
house said the movement was cleared by
its medical team
but some experts say he risked exposing
his security detail to the virus
i was trying to reflect the the upbeat
attitude
dr shawn conley admitted to giving an
overly optimistic view of the
president's health this weekend
you know it came off that we were trying
to hide something which wasn't
necessarily true
the doctors now acknowledge the
president had a high fever and his
oxygen level
an antiviral drug treatments typically
needed for severely ill covered patients
cbs news has learned president trump was
given supplemental oxygen
at the white house friday before
boarding marine one for the trip to the
hospital
just 72 hours into the diagnosis now
conley also caused confusion by
suggesting the president was initially
diagnosed wednesday
before traveling to minnesota for a
rally in new jersey for a fundraiser
the white house later claimed conley
misspoke
himself he has mild symptoms saying that
friday
and then admitting the very next day
that in fact the president's vital signs
had been very concerning
and we are still not on a clear path to
a full recovery
it's still not known how or when
president trump was infected
but last weekend's packed and mostly
massless rose garden ceremony
barrett may have been a super spreader
event
those now infected include the president
first lady
former aide kellyanne conway former new
jersey governor chris christie who is
hospitalized
senators mike lee and tom tillis as well
as the president of notre dame
campaign manager bill stephen and
personal assistant nick luna
are also infected it's not clear what
level of contact tracing is being done
by the white house
are there any people
right now and should go get tested to
make sure they're not continuing to
spread it to other officials
it doesn't seem to be a very concerted
effort underway
vice president mike pence tested
negative for the virus again on sunday
and he is planning to participate in the
vice presidential debate on wednesday
now as for president trump if he is
brought back here to the white house
he will be able to continue his care
there is also an intensive care unit on
site here
and he would remain under the
supervision of his doctors
gail okay ben thank you very much